it's been nearly two weeks since typhoon
doksuri swept through northern China but
its Legacy remains
the roads of Georgia are covered in
thick sludge as our furniture belongings
and merchandise
jungworen estimates he lost stock worth
one million dollars when his electronics
Factory was flooded something he says
could have been prevented
no one gave us an early warning we were
in this Factory in the evening Before
the Flood arrived if we were given more
information we could have easily moved
these items a second floor and saved
them
this area bore the brunt of the storm
the worst to hit the region in living
memory torrential rain caused a nearby
River to overflow but the situation
worsened when authorities decided to use
the city as a flood storage area
diverting water away from neighboring
Beijing
most of the capital was spared but
people living here say they paid the
price
the government should pay us some
compensation because it wasn't just a
natural disaster it was also man-made
the government puts the cost of the
damage at more than 2 billion dollars
but the full scale of the disaster is
still being assessed as is the final
death toll
driving through torador you find the
same scene repeated debris and vehicles
covered in mud people trying to clean up
salvaging what they can and the strong
smell of sewage in the air
city leaders say they're focusing on
cleanup operations disinfection and
Disease Control
the government says it could take up to
a year to restore repair and rebuild
but those living here say they may never
fully recover what was lost
but training you Al Jazeera Georgia
China